C'est un petit pays niché dans les montagnes de l'Himalaya,
loin des magnifiques montagnes d'ici, où les habitants
du Royaume du Bouthan ont décidé de faire quelque chose de différent :
mesurer leur Bonheur Intérieur Brut
plutôt que leur Produit Intérieur Brut.
Et pourquoi pas ?
Après tout, le bonheur n’est pas un privilège réservé aux rares chanceux,
mais un droit fondamental pour tous.
Et qu'est-ce que le bonheur ?
Le bonheur, c'est la liberté de choisir.
La liberté de choisir où vivre,
de faire, d'acheter, de vendre ce que l'on veut
à qui l'on veut, quand et où l'on veut.
D’où vient le choix ?
Et qui vient à l’exprimer, et comment l’exprimons-nous ?
Et bien, une façon d’exprimer ses choix c'est d’utiliser le marché.
Des marchés qui fonctionnent bien proposent des choix, et à terme,
la capacité d'exprimer la recherche de son propre bonheur.
Le célèbre économiste indien, Amartya Sen, s'est vu décerner le prix Nobel
pour sa démonstration que la famine n’est pas tant
une question de disponibilité de nourriture, mais plutôt de capacité à acquérir
ou à se donner le droit d’accéder à cette nourriture via le marché.
En 1984, à l'occasion de ce qui peut être considéré comme l'un
des plus grands crimes contre l'humanité, un million d'habitants sont morts de faim
dans mon pays natal, l'Ethiopie.
Non par manque de nourriture,
-- car il y avait en fait un excédent de nourriture
dans les régions fertiles au sud du pays,
mais parce que les habitants du nord n'avaient pas accès
ou n'avaient pas droit à cette nourriture.
Cet événement a marqué un tournant dans ma vie.
L’écrasante majorité des africains aujourd’hui est paysanne.
Et la plupart des paysans sont, dans l’ensemble,
de petits exploitants en termes de surface cultivée, et de très petits
exploitants en termes de capital disponible.
L’agriculture africaine aujourd’hui est parmi, ou est la plus sous-capitalisée du monde.
Seulement 7% de la terre cultivable en Afrique est irriguée,
contre 40% en Asie.
Les cultivateurs africains utilisent 22 kg de fertilisant par hectare,
contre 144 kg en Asie.
La densité routière est 6 fois plus importante en Asie qu'en Afrique rurale.
Il y a 8 fois plus de tracteurs en Amérique Latine
et 3 fois plus de tracteurs en Asie qu'en Afrique.
Le petit cultivateur d'Afrique aujourd'hui a peu de choix,
donc peu de liberté.
Sa subsistance est prédéterminée
par les conditions de la misère noire.
Il vend sur le marché lorsque les prix sont au plus bas,
avec les maigres fruits d'un dur labeur, après les récoltes,
parce qu'il n'a pas le choix.
Elle retourne au marché
quelques mois plus tard, lorsque les prix sont au plus haut, pendant
la saison dite maigre - quand la nourriture se fait rare -
car elle doit nourrir sa famille et n'a pas le choix.
La vraie question est de savoir comment on peut développer les marchés
pour exploiter le pouvoir d'innovation et l'esprit d'entreprise
qui existent en Afrique rurale.
Theodore Schultz, économiste également renommé,
a reçu en 1974 le prix Nobel après avoir démontré que les agriculteurs
sont efficaces, mais pauvres.
Ce qui signifie qu'ils sont rationnels
et cherchent à s'enrichir comme tout le monde.
Bien mais, nous n’avons plus besoin
d'autres Prix Nobel pour savoir que ces agriculteurs veulent une place équitable
sur le marché et qu'ils veulent gagner de l'argent, comme tout le monde.
Et il est clair que maintenant, on sait au moins que
l’Afrique est prête pour faire des affaires.
Et des affaires fondées sur l’agriculture.
Il y a plus de vingt ans, le monde insistait pour que les marchés africains
soient libéralisés, que les économies soient structurellement adaptées.
Cela signifiait que les gouvernements allaient devoir se retirer
de la vente et de l'achat,
ce qu'ils faisaient d'ailleurs de façon assez inefficace,
et laisser s'opérer la magie du marché privé.
Que s'est-il passé pendant ces 25 dernières années ?
L'Afrique s'est-elle nourrie tout seule ?
Nos agriculteurs sont-ils devenus des acteurs commerciaux hautement productifs ?
Je pense que nous sommes réunis dans cette pièce
sûrement parce que nous savons qu'en fait, l'Afrique est la seule région
du monde où la faim et la malnutrition vont s'accroître
dans les dix prochaines années.
Où la facture d’importation de nourriture
a doublé en vingt ans.
Où la production de nourriture par tête
a stagné et où l’usage des fertilisants n'a fait que diminuer.
Alors pourquoi les marchés agricoles n’ont-ils pas été à la hauteur des attentes ?
Les réformes du marché inspirées par l’Occident
-- et j’ai passé quelque 15 années à voyager sur le continent
et faire de la recherche sur les marchés agricoles. J'ai interviewé
des commerçants de 10 à 15 pays - des centaines de commerçants --
pour comprendre ce qui allait de travers dans notre réforme des marchés.
Et il m’apparaît que les réformes pourraient bien
avoir jeté le bébé avec l’eau du bain.
Tout comme son agriculture,
les marchés africains sont hautement sous-capitalisés et inefficaces.
D'après notre expérience dans ce continent, nous savons que
les coûts de transactions pour entrer sur le marché,
et les risques associés sur les marchés agricoles,
sont extrêmement élevés.
En fait, seulement un tiers de la production agricole
de l'Afrique parvient à atteindre le marché.
Les marchés de l’Afrique sont faibles non seulement à cause de la faiblesse des infrastructures
routières ou de télécommunications, mais aussi à cause
de la quasi absence des institutions de marchés nécessaires telles que
l’information commerciale, les barèmes et les normes de qualité
ainsi que des moyens fiables pour mettre en relation les acheteurs et les vendeurs.
A cause de cela, typiquement les acheteurs et les vendeurs de denrées échangent à l’intérieur de cercles restreints
dans d’étroits réseaux de connaissances et de confiance.
Et de ce fait, lorsque le grain change de mains
-- et j’ai évalué qu’il change de mains 4 ou 5 fois dans
son parcours du producteur au consommateur --
chaque fois qu'il change de main -- et j’ai vu cela partout en Afrique rurale --
il change également de sac.
Je trouvais cela incroyablement bizarre.
Je me suis vraiment rendue compte de cela car -- comme me le disaient les commerçants
encore et encore -- c’était la seule façon qu’avaient les gens de savoir ce qu’ils achetaient
en terme de quantité et de qualité de produits.
Et ceci a vraiment d’énormes conséquences
sur la capacité des marchés à répondre rapidement à des signaux sur les prix,
et dans des situations où il y a pénurie par exemple.
Cela a aussi des conséquences de coûts élevés.
J’ai mis en évidence que 26 % de la marge commerciale
du fait de l'absence de barèmes de notation
et de normes, et d'information sur le marché,
sont absorbés par ces changements constants de sacs.
Et cela conduit à un coût de manipulation très élevé.
Pour leur part, les petits paysans qui produisent le gros de la production agricole en Afrique
arrivent au marché avec virtuellement aucune information -- aveugles.
Espérant qu’ils auront
quelque demande pour leur production,
et complètement à la merci des marchands
du plus proche marché local, le seul marché qu’ils connaissent --
où ils se trouvent incapables de négocier de meilleurs prix ou de réduire leur risque.
A propos de risque, nous avons vu que la volatilité
des prix des récoltes alimentaires en Afrique est la plus élevée du monde.
En Afrique, les petits agriculteurs sont les plus touchés par ce risque.
Je crois qu'il n'existe pas d'autres régions au monde, ou d'autres périodes de l'histoire
où les paysans aient eu à supporter le type de risque
que les paysans africains doivent supporter.
Et à mon avis, il n’y a tout simplement pas d’endroit au monde
ayant conduit son agriculture au niveau de risque
auquel nos paysans africains font face aujourd’hui.
En Ethiopie par exemple, la variation du prix du maïs
atteint rien moins que 50 % d'une année sur l'autre.
Ce genre de risque du marché est stupéfiant, et à des conséquences directes
non seulement sur la motivation des agriculteurs à investir
dans des techniques à plus forts rendements comme des semences ou des fertilisants modernes
mais aussi sur la sécurité alimentaire.
Pour citer un exemple, entre 2001 et 2002,
les producteurs de maïs éthiopiens connurent 2 années de récoltes exceptionnelles.
Cela, à cause du faible système de marché,
a occasionné un effondrement de 80% du prix du maïs dans le pays.
Cela a même rendu non-rentable pour certains paysans le simple fait de récolter les céréales dans les champs.
On a estimé que quelques 300 000 tonnes de céréales
ont été laissées à pourrir sur pieds début 2002.
A peine 6 mois plus tard, en Juillet 2002, l’Ethiopie annonçait une crise alimentaire majeure,
de la magnitude de celle de 1984 -- un risque de famine pour 14 millions de personnes.
Ce qui s’est également produit cette année-là
c’est que dans les zones où les pluies avaient été bonnes, et où les paysans
avaient précédemment produit un excédent de céréales, les paysans avaient décidé
de se retirer du marché des fertilisants, de ne plus les utiliser,
et avaient diminué leur consommation de fertilisants de 27 %.
Un exemple tragique de développement interrompu,
d’un bourgeon de révolution verte gâché.
Et cela n’est pas propre à l’Ethiopie,
mais se produit encore et encore partout en Afrique.
Bon, je ne suis pas ici pour me lamenter sur la situation, ou me tordre les mains de désespoir.
Je suis ici pour vous dire qu’il y a du changement dans l’air.
L’Afrique d’aujourd’hui n’est plus l’Afrique qui attend des aides,
ou les prescriptions à l’emporte-pièce d’un expert étranger.
L’Afrique a appris, ou apprend – quelque peu lentement --
que les marchés ne se font pas tout seuls.
Dans les années 1980, il était très à la mode
de parler de juste prix.
Il est paru un livre très influent sur ce sujet;
qui traitait surtout de la façon de bannir les gouvernements du marché.
Nous comprenons désormais qu’obtenir de juste prix n’est pas seulement
une question d’incitations sur les prix, mais aussi d’investissements dans une bonne infrastructure
et dans les institutions appropriées et nécessaires pour créer
les conditions capables de libérer les énergies innovantes dans le marché.
Lorsque les conditions requises seront réunies, on sait
que l’innovation est prête à submerger l’Afrique rurale,
comme partout ailleurs.
Il y a presque 3 ans, je décidai de quitter mon poste confortable
en tant qu'expert-économiste à la Banque Mondiale à Washington,
et revenir dans mon pays natal, l'Ethiopie,
après avoir passé 30 ans à l'étranger.
Je l'ai fait pour une raison bien simple.
Après avoir passé plus de dix ans
à comprendre, étudier, et essayer de convaincre les politiques et les donateurs
à propos de ce qui allait mal dans les marchés de l’Afrique,
j’ai décidé qu’il était temps d’y faire quelque chose.
Je dirige actuellement en Ethiopie, une passionnante nouvelle initiative
visant à établir la première Bourse de Marchandises éthiopienne (ECX).
Bon, la Bourse de Marchandises, en tant que concept,
ce n’est pas nouveau.
En fait, en 1848, 82 marchands et producteurs de céréales s’étaient réunis
dans une petite ville au carrefour de l’Illinois et du lac Michigan
pour améliorer le commerce entre eux.
Ce fut bien sûr, la naissance de la Bourse de Commerce de Chicago
qui est la bourse de marchandises la plus célèbre au monde.
La Bourse de Commerce de Chicago fut créée à l’époque
pour exactement les mêmes raisons
qui font que nos paysans d’aujourd’hui profiteraient d’une bourse de marchandises.
Dans le Middle West américain, les paysans envoyaient des cargaisons de céréales
par péniches au marché de Chicago.
Mais une fois arrivé, si aucun acheteur ne se présentait,
ou si les prix chutaient d’un coup, les paysans supportaient de terribles pertes.
Et en fait, il arrivait qu’ils jettent le grain dans le lac Michigan,
plutôt que de supporter le coût du transport du retour.
Donc, le besoin d’éviter ces énormes risques et de gigantesques pertes
a conduit à la naissance du marché à terme et du système sous-jacent
de calibrage de la qualité du grain et d’accusé de réception -- émettant des reçus de magasins
sur la base de la nature de la transaction à effectuer.
A partir de là, la plus grande innovation apparut,
et qui permit aux acheteurs et aux vendeurs de s’échanger des céréales
sans avoir en réalité à les inspecter physiquement et visuellement.
Cela signifiait que les céréales pouvaient faire l’objet d’un commerce à très longue distance
et même à travers le temps -- jusqu’à 18 mois en avance.
Cette innovation est au cœur de la transformation de l’agriculture américaine,
et de l’accession de Chicago au rang de marché global,
marché agricole, superpuissance à partir de ce qu’elle était -- une petite ville régionale.
Or, durant le siècle dernier,
nous avons considéré les bourses de marchandises comme l’apanage
des pays industrialisés occidentaux.
Et les prix de référence du coton, du café, du cacao --
pourtant principalement produits du Sud–
sont en réalité des prix de référence, des prix établis dans ces
bourses de marchandises des pays du Nord.
Mais c'est en train de changer.
Et nous voyons poindre un renversement,
propulsé principalement par les technologies de l’information.
Un changement dans la domination du marché en faveur des marchés émergents.
Et au cours de la précédente décennie, on voit que la part des pays occidentaux --
et ceci est la part des USA dans les échanges mondiaux --
a presque diminué de moitié sur la seule dernière décennie.
De la même façon, il y a eu une croissance explosive en Inde, par exemple,
où les fermiers utilisent des bourses -- en croissance
de 270 % par an depuis trois ans.
Ce phénomène est alimenté par une technologie à bas coût, VSAT (Very Small Aperture Satellite),
qui essaye de façon très déterminée de toucher les paysans pour les relier au marché.
La bourse de marchandises de Dalian en Chine a dépassé il y a 3 ans
en 2004 le Chicago Board of Trade pour devenir
la deuxième bourse mondiale de marchandises.
Actuellement, en Ethiopie, nous sommes en train de concevoir
la première bourse organisée de marchandises d'Ethiopie.
Nous n’essayons pas de faire un copier-coller du modèle de Chicago
mais nous créons un système unique fait spécifiquement pour répondre
aux besoins et aux réalités de l'Ethiopie,
des petits paysans d’Ethiopie.
Donc, l'ECX est une bourse éthiopienne pour l'Ethiopie.
Nous sommes en train de créer un système au service de tous les acteurs du marché.
Il crée intégrité, confiance, efficience, transparence
et permet aux petits fermiers de gérer les risques que j’ai décrits.
Dans notre création d’une bourse de marchandises en Ethiopie,
nous avons fait une chose relativement unique, qui est
d’adopter une perspective intégrée,
ce que nous appelons l’avantage ECX.
L’avantage ECX crée pratiquement l’écosystème tout entier
dans lequel le marché se développera.
Et cela à cause d’une chose que nous avons apprise
au cours de la décennie écoulée passée à étudier le développement des marchés africains :
l’approche fragmentaire ne fonctionne pas.
Vous avez ici un donateur qui essaie de développer l’information de marché,
un autre là essayant de mettre en place des normes et barèmes,
un autre l’ICT (Technologie de l’Information et de la Communication) et encore un autre l’entreposage – ou les reçus d’entreposage.
Dans notre approche en Ethiopie,
nous avons décidé de mettre en place tout l’écosystème,
ou environnement, dans lequel l’échange se déroule.
Cela signifie que la bourse va opérer un système d’échanges commerciaux
qui démarrera sous forme d’une criée ouverte.
Car nous ne pensons pas que le pays soit prêt pour un système complètement électronique.
Mais en même temps, nous ferons une chose qu’aucune bourse
n’a jamais faite dans le monde, qui est d’opérer elle-même une sorte
de cybercafé dans les zones rurales.
Ainsi les paysans et les petits marchands
pourront réellement se rendre dans un centre terminal -- que nous appelons
centre terminal d’accès distant– et véritablement,
sans qu’ils aient à acheter un ordinateur ou qu’ils doivent apprendre
comment fonctionnent toutes ces choses, ils pourront simplement voir
se dérouler les transactions à la corbeille d’Addis Abeba.
En même temps, ce qui est essentiel à ce marché c’est que
-- et, c’est encore une innovation spécifique à notre bourse –
celle-ci exploitera des entrepôts dans tout le pays,
dans lesquels seront donnée une certification de qualité et délivrés des reçus d’entrée en stocks.
Et à terme, nous exploiterons un système interne de compensation
garantissant que le paiement est fait correctement,
au bon montant et au bon moment,
de sorte que de façon terre à terre nous créerons de la confiance et de l’intégrité dans le système.
A l’évidence, nous travaillons avec des acteurs boursiers,
et à mesure que nous développons le marché lui-même,
nous développons l’infrastructure règlementaire et l’architecture légale --
l’architecture légale générale permettant à ce marché de fonctionner.
Donc en fait, notre déclaration
passera devant le parlement le mois prochain.
Ce qui importe vraiment, c’est qu’ECX exploitera un système d’information de marché
qui propagera électroniquement les prix en temps réel vers les paysans dans tout le pays,
en utilisant la technologie VSAT pour mettre en place une diffusion électronique des prix.
directement vers les paysans
Ce que cela change, c’est que cela transforme fondamentalement
la relation du paysan au marché.
Alors qu’avant, le paysan pensait local
c’est-à-dire qu’il se déplaçait au marché des environs
soit à 8 à 10 kms en moyenne
pour y vendre ce qu’il avait,
sans aucune idée des meilleurs prix ou de quoi que ce soit
-- maintenant les paysans viennent avec la connaissance des prix sur le marché national.
Et ils commencent à penser national, et même global.
Ils commencent à prendre des décisions non seulement commerciales et marketing
mais aussi concernant les plantes à semer en fonction de l’information
provenant des marchés à terme.
Et ils viennent au marché en sachant quels tarifs
seront appliqués à leurs produits selon leur qualité.
Donc tout ceci va changer les paysans.
Cela transformera aussi la manière dont les marchands commercent.
Cela les amènera à cesser les simples opérations de gré à gré, d’arbitrage limité
pour vraiment penser stratégiquement à la manière de transporter des céréales
sur de longues distances entre régions déficitaires et régions excédentaires.
L’Ethiopie peut elle y arriver ?
Cela semble très ambitieux.
Mais cela créera de nouvelles opportunités.
Nous pensons que cette initiative demande une grande volonté politique,
et il faudra aligner les secteurs financiers et des Technologies de l’Information et de la Communication,
et vraiment même l’architecture légale sous-jacente.
Nous croyons que les vents du changement soufflent, et que nous pouvons le faire.
ECX est le marché du nouveau millénaire pour l’Ethiopie
et il démarrera dans à peu près huit mois.
Le dernier parlement de notre siècle s’est ouvert avec l’annonce
faite par notre président au pays que ceci était l’initiative économique la plus importante
pour le pays aujourd’hui.
Nous croyons que les enjeux sont élevés
mais que le gain attendu l’est encore plus.
ECX, en outre, peut devenir une plateforme d’échanges pour un marché panafricain
de denrées agricoles.
Le marché domestique éthiopien a une valeur de près d’un milliard de dollars.
Et nous avons le sentiment que si, au cours des 5 prochaines années,
l’Ethiopie peut capter 40 %, juste 40 % de son marché domestique
et ajouter seulement 25 % en valeur à ce marché, la valeur du marché aura doublé.
Le marché éthiopien agricole représente 30 % de plus
que la production de céréales Sud Africaine
-- et en fait, l’Ethiopie est le second plus important producteur de maïs d’Afrique.
Le potentiel est donc là
La volonté est là.
L’engagement est là.
Nous avons le sentiment que nous avons une proposition de valeur gagnante
pour transformer les choix des paysans, faire croître notre agriculture,
et pour faire changer l’Afrique.
Notre affaire, c’est de trouver notre bonheur.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)